shane mcclanahan on the mount as we
welcome you back to
pitching central the pitching pipeline
of tampa bay
and he has had a fantastic rookie year a
guy who had baptism by fire splashed
across the front pages here last fall
because he was the first pitcher ever to
make a major league debut in the
postseason when his number was called in
the top of the ninth inning against the
yankees no less in game one of last
year's alds he's a local kid
developed right in the ray's backyard
university of south florida makes his
offseason home in tampa st pete and is
ready to make his 16th start of the year
here tonight his first ever against the
red sox now the 1-1 lift in the air
towards right field pushing margot back
to the warning check but he's got room
in front of the wall when he makes the
catch to start the night it'll fly out
to right field one away ball and two
strikes to debors
into left center field to base it
there's a heck of an at-bat for rafi not
rung up on an o2 pitch that was close
endeavours slings one into left for the
red sox first hit second baseman lyle
shaded towards the middle of the pitch
swing and a miss he struck him out now
that was high heat fastball at 97. so
martinez was looking down for the slider
but the fastball got blown by him two
away and that's where you want the
fastball elevated the target should be
right at the catcher's mask a little bit
above
unhittable up there one ball two strikes
devers are short lead at first the pitch
to beau guards is swung going to miss
strength three same pattern that he did
against jd martinez slider down and then
fastball up and an impressive first
inning for shane mcclanahan at the end
of half just for nick pavetta getting
the start against the rays he's been
really really good against the race in
two starts this season first start of
the season went five innings scattered
two hits
and walked four while striking out four
then his last time against the raise on
june the 24th he went six and two thirds
did not allow a hit before he was taken
out of the game walked a couple and
struck out eight a pretty firm fastball
pavetta into the wind the first pitch of
the first two lao is blooped into
shallow left field racing in his jd
martinez and he makes a hip high grab on
the run
jd surprises you in left field really
nice play there he was deep swinging a
miss he struck him out with a curveball
and meadows goes down
excellent start for pavetta his first
punch shot and with two down here comes
nelson cruz here's the 2-2 to cruise
swinging a high pop-up on the infield
vasquez pointing down the first baseline
dalbeck rushes in and in foul territory
he's there to make the play and very
quick work made by pavetta now here he
comes swinging a line drive out to shore
put on a hop it's taken by bogarts
behind the bag at second to his left he
throws to first for the odd yandi hit
the ball hard there
that's the second out of the unit pretty
good exit velocity almost 108 but on the
ground and bogarts hadn't played
perfectly two gun bases empty now for
the switch-hitting shortstop rookie
wander franco that has got the velocity
back that's encouraging he was 94 in his
last start 96 at the peak tonight o2
curveball grounded to the left side and
again right into the defense devers was
alone over there he throws to first and
nick pavetta is answering the bell
tonight slips up six down the o2 pitch
strike three called
and nice comeback there by shane
mcclanahan after the lead-off walk for
the number nine guy he gets the next
three guys
rather quickly two gone for mike zanino
eight in a row retired by nick pavetta
to start the night as here's a pitch and
it's low ball four and so mike cenino
works a two-out walk and the rays get
their first base runner a walk for the
number nine hitter themselves zenino
down at first base and brandon lau steps
in now
[Applause]
to right
watches it fly
number 23 for brandon lau just enough
carry to clear the yellow railing and
the razor on the board first on this
sunday night and a great swing here the
slider and just a little cement mixer 86
miles an hour sped up his back for lau
the sweet spot middle end a little back
flip he's got all kinds of pop good
player in san diego good player in tampa
but he's really turned into a
different type of hitter as a boston red
sox fired deep left center field at the
wall gone home run hunter renfro golf
did a pitch at the top of the zone i
wasn't sure if he got all of it when it
left the bat but it escapes kevin
kiermeier and the center field wall
426 feet on the home run by renfro sox
now back to within a run at 2-1 we
talked about the fastball being hit hard
this year retro game on top of this
96 mile an hour fastball all over it 97
in 104 out now he delivers 1-1
high drive way up into the dome left
center field meadows and camera moving
back it's kk jumping up in front of the
wall to make the catch that thing seemed
like it went to the center of the dome
here at tropicana field and caremeyer
went to the deepest part of the yard
which is that little notch right where
the mascots are now coming out for the
mascot race they couldn't wait and
thankfully for the raise kier meyer made
the play end of four and a half wild
pitch puts a runner in scoring position
one two tomorrow girl slashed into right
center it gets down for a base head
around third is broncos steaming to the
plate renfrow's throw up the line and
it's three to one raise rvi single for
manuel margot for the raise in the last
10 minutes they showed you what they're
all about defense athleticism with the
platinum glove kirbyer and now a simple
base hit a wild pitch and a base hit
that nine out of ten runners cannot
score from second base uh hansel robles
is on to make his red sox debut
acquired as a part of the minnesota fire
sale he came from the twins along with
cash considerations
cruz with the ground ball to short
to third and they cut down the lead
runner and a rare mistake on the base
path for the raise that brings up g-man
choi struck out twice tonight looking
and swinging robles checks cruz at first
a one pitch
ground ball to first good play by
dalbeck makes the throw to second back
to first and the double play a 3-6-3
double play good play by dolbeck on both
ends both to start it and then to finish
it
the red sox get out of a little bit of
trouble here leo one swinging a fly ball
to right pushing back margaux at the
warning track to the wall makes the
catch up against the wall crashes into
it and holds on
tagging at second and going to third
is verdugo but what a catch by margot
hernandez with verdugo at third bounced
gets away from the
catcher and verdugo will score red sox
say thank you very much they'll take the
run
zanino who done such a great job tonight
blocking pitches at the plate couldn't
come up with that breaking ball that
bounced a good foot and a half in front
of him now the 1-0 pitch swinging the
ground ball back up toward the middle
wander is right there we'll flip the
second to get the fourth and that will
retire the side
meadows one for three tonight into the
opposite field martinez on the move
sliding and making the catch
jd making his 17th start in the outfield
this year alex cora has used him out
there a lot time runs at third go ahead
run at first base with two out
this is about as good a finish as we
could have asked for here it is swinging
a pump fly shallow center out goes lao
in comes margot and the rays have swept
the red sox